I guess I I wanted to ask you something
yes I mean okay Jonathan and I recorded
a song which we didn't end up keeping
called I want to get this right and it
was this kind of like throwback power
ballad where we're singing to each other
like rock stars I want to get this right
baby I want to thrill you in the way you
deserve I should just come out and say
I want to get this right baby why is
this so hard this is hard no no no it
was a jam I loved it I saw a version of
it with rough animation I was like this
is incredible I want to give you what
you want I want to be the man you choose
I think that's a song that's very
personal to us and our courtship because
without puking on shoes Bobby and I when
we were dating he had all of his heart
and not a whole lot of skills maybe how
do I don't think a lot of boys grow up
with romantic models I gotta get this
right no no no learn how to be smooth
and really make a woman feel loved
it's it wasn't something that that I
grew up learning about or doing to this
day we still love it we really wanted to
give him that opportunity to propose
from his heart and to get it right
himself oh here's the thing I've got a
ring I didn't bring no suits and he does
it in his own way and I love I love his
journey I didn't get this right
it was so catchy but as I was learning
it my kids were picking up on it and we
still to this day sing it weekly at my
husband I've never been too worldly in
the ways of
I haven't had to woo thank goodness in
about 15 years I don't think I would be
up to date on the wooing process at this
point I'm really happy my wife tired
it's me all right it's mistake of your
life we didn't even kiss you I'm not
good at giving wooing advice I'm not
very comfortable with the idea of that I
think the advice for anyone with wooing
women is it's not what you think it is
it's not being smooth it's being
authentic much better to be Prince
sincere instead of Prince Charming right
that's a nice word I think that's a
Chris office yeah we're gonna get this
right
[Music]